[موسيقى]
اول حد قتلته وكان مين من الضحايا
انا الضحايا عندي كتير يا باشا انا بابا
المجال
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بلما تم طرح برومو مسلسل بابا
المجال للفنان مصطفى شعبان وقبل رمضان
وهناك حاله فضول وجدل كبيرين والان وبعد
ايام من عرض العمل يبدو ان الجمهور اهدا
ربما اعجابهم القصه التي تدور في منطقه
شعبيه يمر فيها البطل بمواقف وازمات حيث
يعمل في مجال التجاره ويواجه خصم شديد جدا
وهو باسم سمره لا انا بشوف انه مسلسل شيق
لانه قصه شعبيه
بتلمس كل واحد ماشي في الشارع
تلمس كل واحد في سواء في منطقه شعبيه او
مش في منطقه شعبيه في مصر او كمان في
العالم العربي الموضوع اللي فيه
المسلسل بيهم اغلبيه الناس
مش هلاقي حاجه اقولها اكثر من نجوم مرعب
يعني بتشرف بيهم واضافه كبيره جدا لي في
مسيرتي يعني وضفا للعمل كمان شخصيه مراسي
هي شخصيه يعني شعبيه وكده طبعا مسلسل هو
كله صراع ما بين الخير والشر
احداث كتيره مراسي احداث العمل يضم كوكبه
من نجوم يثني الجمهور والنقاد عليهم دائما
يقال انهم خطفوا الاضواء في هذا العمل وهم
الفنانه سوسن بدر والفنان رياض الخولي
والد ووالده مصطفى شعبان في العمل اللي
يستهدف الجيل الجديد والشباب وقيمه
العائله والعلاقات ما بينهم كبير زي مصطفى
شعبان احب جدا اني اكون معاه في رمضان في
علاقه خاصه جدا بتربطها بابنها
بتتطرحها الظروف ان هي اللي تتولى تربيته
ومن ساعه ما بيبقى الطفل رضيع يعني
وبنشوف بقى الرحله بينهم هم الاتنين
الرحله الطويله دي بتبقى فيها ايه حلو
وايه مش حلو وايه يمروا صعب خصوصا ان هي
هتمر بالظروف صحيه
بتضطروا بقى هو اللي يشيل مسئوليه في
الفتره دي دي يعني كلام كده سريع عن
الموضوع شخصيه جميله
خطيبه زين
ويعني متربيين
مربيها من وهي صغيره
وكبروا مع بعض ولسه هنشوف الاحداث ان شاء
الله وهي مجموعه رائعه من النجوم اللي
مبسوطه قوي قوي بالعمل معهم نستعرض الان
بعض الاراء حول العالم
[موسيقى]
جيتك دي خربطت رسمه